- Une petite garde-robe,
C'est pas grand,
c c c c'est chez nous.
- C'est un séjour au motel
qui n'a rien de touristique
JACQUELINE SMITH- La raison qu'é
dans une chambre de motel,
c'est que, justement, le loyuvu.
- Une hausse de 350 $ par mois.
Loin des moyens de Jacagagagaga.
- Soit qu'on abandonne un char,
puis qu'on fait du pouce,
un pour aller travaillerbubububn
pour une "drive". Il y a
des coupures qui étaient
obligées d'être faites.
Ça, c'est appartement...
- Ils ont plutôt choisi
de partir. La chambre de motel
abordable sur le marché.
- C'est pas normal pour personne
être
puis pas être capable de vivre
pleines s s s s un appartement
parce que le coût de la vie
es
- C'est pour éviter que ce genre
d'histoireèèèèète que
le gouvernement de Blaine Higgs
change
... et limite l'augmentation
des  3,8 % pendant
un an. La mesure sera
L'opposition officielle et les
représentants des locataires
restent sur leur faim.
ROB McKEE, député, Parti libéral
du N.-B., Moncton-Centre
- On regarde d'autres provincess
qui sont trois fois meilleurs
que le nôtre, des 1-1,5 %
dans d'autres provinces.oioioion
assez? Je pense pas.
MATTHEW HAYES, Coalition pour
droits des locataires du N.-B.na
pas décidé de prendre une mesure
plus permanente maintenant? Ce
n'est pas une mesure radicale.ei
de 50 % sur 3 ans les impô
fonciers provinciaux pour
les propriétaires d'immeublet.ts
doutent que les locataires
en profitent réellement.
RICHARD SAILLANT, économidididi,
c'est d'essayer d'in
à la construction résidentielle,
mais on fait face majeures de pt
dans cette indus
- L'Association des
propriétaires d'appartements
que la mesure ne suffira pas
à com d d d d d d d d d d d d d.
35,2 millions, c'est le surplus
prévu pour l'exercice 2022-2023.
Si le bugdet du Nouveau-
ararararararararararararararara,
bien des ménages de la provincee